I'll going give you a bit more
detail you have to do an expression with
the hand so my hand is at right angles
really right if it's not at right angles
and it's sort of like halfway there I've
started closing up this Gap
here
so what happens is his wrist doesn't
turn all the way over it stays at a if I
had a Joe it would be like at that
angle I need need
it parallel is it parallel flat I need
it this way so the thumb can go in there
now now it might seem a small thing but
if I only turn it a little bit my thumb
gets a a
grip but it never gets the flat the the
flat can't of the thumb can't get on
it I get a bit there but the thumb now
has to bend to get there
if I turn it I just put the thumb in and
it fits can you all see
that
okay that's what makes it
strong so you've got to crank it
around You' got to crank that round
until that thumb has got that
firmly cuz what we're going to do is
we're not going to just do she and Aggy
and this thumb is going to be really
important to where where it's
placed when we get doing higher forms
like yokam manucci and that you're going
to be finding it's really difficult to
get that Thumb in in
time cuz the other hand gets busy to to
come in right so so we're starting off
with a S one but this isn't turned
enough look so I've got to crank
it as hard as I can crank it I need to
crank
it okay so please you know this is why
you've come all this distance this is
why you've paid your money this is why
you're taking time out of your
life it won't be just one technique you
get today if you understand oh it
star do you know if you understand one
point it goes to many points but even
with all my trying I might not get
through to you today but perhaps John
Nick Richard Doug you know somebody will
they'll go co why didn't I see that all
those years ago and that was exactly the
same with me with CID Sensei even though
he was to me the best out there I didn't
get it I got my remagi off yada Sensei I
got my uprightness off chba Sensei so I
stole what I needed CU I couldn't see it
uh within my own teacher right but
this to me is O senses iido but cyto
senses in my
image crank it over okay done